30 seconds from now i may get the phone
call you know destroy my world
you have such a great great great great
outlook and
see for me i've been so humiliated and
humbled
and i don't i don't particularly mind
public humiliation and i've done enough
self-development to overcome some of
that where you just do push-ups on the
street or you yell for no reason or
whatever it may be
but maybe a part of my background
anxiety is the fact that
i either one feel bad that i have such a
great great great great great
life and that not only is there so much
suffering but
it could be else and at any moment
i know that there were other points in
my life where right when i thought i had
it figured out is when it all
falls apart and so maybe i'm wondering
do i have it too good and then i
i'm wondering like am i i might just
think i'm thinking myself into my own
suffering but i'm not suffering that
much like i'm i'm
way overblowing it maybe
i want to question subjective we should
honor our suffering
even if you say well other people have
it a lot worse than me and
and i'm saying this because i'm guilty
of it all the time i always tell
myself well my suffering is nothing
compared to the suffering syria
to the sufferings bangladesh to the
suffering in africa but
in that sense i don't do justice to
myself because you know
for good or bad reason i do suffer so
yeah i wouldn't go there but look the
the most ins
you know what the most insidious form of
taking yourself too seriously is
is when you tell yourself [ __ ] i take
myself too seriously and i shouldn't
that's the worst instance of taking
yourself too seriously
because if you don't take yourself too
seriously you are kind towards yourself
it is taking yourself too seriously to
say i'm taking myself too seriously yeah
yeah okay okay please explain because
you told me that so now if i was to
listen to it are you telling myself
because if you think if you think it's
so important
that you shouldn't take yourself so
seriously
then you are taking yourself too
seriously otherwise you would say yeah
okay i'm taking myself so seriously
it's what is right i take myself too
seriously yeah
yeah okay man you have such but you're
like oh
[ __ ] i'm taking myself too seriously and
i shouldn't i have to do something about
it
what do you think that is it's you
taking yourself extra
seriously so not taking yourself too
seriously
entails doesn't imply it entails being
kind
to yourself